>>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THE
PROGRAM WILL BEGIN SHORTLY, WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE.>>
LADIES IN JUDGMENT PLEASE
SILENCE YOUR CELL PHONE AND
MOBILE DEVICES AT THIS TIME.
BRICK
>>> GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME
TO COLUMBIA'S WORLD LEADERS
FORM.
I AM JOHN COATSWORTH, PROVOST
OF THE UNIVERSITY AND I'M
HONORED  TO WELCOME TO HIS
EXCELLENCY ANDREJ PLENKOVI
PRIME MINISTER OF THE REPUBLIC
OF CROATIA  FOR TALK ON A VERY
TIMELY TOPIC.
THE FUTURE OF EUROPE, THE
CROATIAN PROSPECTIVE.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE PRESENCE OF IVAN SIMONOVIC
AMBASSADOR OF CROATIA TO THE
U.S. AS WELL AS THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PRESIDENT'S
DELEGATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
COLUMBIA'S NOBLE POLICY
INITIATIVE FOR COSPONSORING
THIS EVENT A KNOWLEDGE THE
PRESENCE OF ITS DIRECTOR.
>> CROATIA IS AT A PIVOTAL
POINT IN ITS DEVELOPMENT.
IN 2013 IT ACHIEVED A LONG
SOUGHT AFTER GOAL.
THE NATION BECAME THE NEWEST
MEMBER OF THE EU.
HE IS UNIQUELY ABLE TO EXPLAIN
THE MEANING OF THESE EVENTS.
HIS BACKGROUND AS A STUDENT
ACTIVIST ALONG WITH HIS
SUBSEQUENT EXPERIENCE AS A
DIPLOMAT AND POLICYMAKER GIVE
HIM THE NECESSARY BACKGROUND
AND EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE TO
HELP AS HE DID, NEGOTIATE
CROATIA'S ACCESSION TO THE EU,
BRING THOSE TO A CONCLUSION AND
THEN CAMPAIGNED TO GENERATE
PUBLIC SUPPORT WITHIN CROATIA
FOR MEMBERSHIP BY EXPLAINING
THE PROCESS OF ACCESSION AND
THE VALUE OF BECOMING PART OF
THE UNION.
HE IS THE MEMBER OF THE
CROATIAN PARLIAMENT AND ONE OF
THE NATIONS REPRESENTATIVE TO
THE EUROPEAN UNION.
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE THE
GLOBAL RECESSION, CROATIA'S
EXPERIENCING SUSTAINED IF
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
ECONOMIC INSTABILITY CONTINUES
TO CAST A SHADOW OVER THE
NATION AND THE REGION.
THE NOTABLE ECONOMIC RIGHT SPOT
IS A RECORD BREAKING NUMBER OF
TOURISTS MANY ATTRACTED BY THE
FACT IT'S THE NAME FILMING FOR
KING'S LANDING IN THE GAME OF
THRONES.
THE MILLION -- THEY SERVE AS A
REMINDER THAT DIFFERENCES IN
GEOGRAPHY AND NATIONAL HISTORY
SOMETIMES PROVE SECONDARY TO
THE POWER OF GLOBAL TRENDS.
THIS PAST SUMMER'S HEADLINES IN
CROATIA SPOKE OF BATTLES OVER
IMMIGRATION AND THE STATUS OF
REFUGEES, THE RISE OF
ULTRANATIONALISM INTENSIFYING
DEBATE ABOUT TAX REFORM AND
NATURAL DISASTERS INCLUDING
CATASTROPHIC FLOODING AND
DOZENS OF WILDFIRES.
GRACIOUS LIKE YOU HAVE AS IS
PRIME MINISTER THE MAN WHO IS
EXPRESSING CAPABLE OF
RESPONDING TO ALL OF THESE
CRISES AT THE SAME TIME.
WILL NOW HEAR FROM THE PRIME
MINISTER ABOUT NAVIGATING THE
CHALLENGES AND LEARN FROM HIS
EXPERT PERSPECTIVE ON EUROPE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING HIS
EXCELLENCY ANDREJ PLENKOVI
PRIME MINISTER OF THE REPUBLIC
OF CROATIA .[ APPLAUSE ]
>> GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
FOR THIS MORE THAN PERTINENT
INTRODUCTION.
LET ME EXTEND MY APOLOGIES FOR
BEING LATE.
WE HAD SEVERAL COMMITMENTS AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE DURING THE UN
GENERAL ASSEMBLY.
TRAFFIC HAS BEEN NOT AN ALLY
THE LAST TWO DAYS.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO YOU
ON THIS FORM WERE SOME OF MY
PREDECESSORS HAVE SPOKEN AS
WELL ABOUT CROATIAN PERSPECTIVE
ON THE FUTURE OF THE EU.
YOU WILL KNOW THAT WE HAVE BEEN
A MEMBER FOR ONLY FOUR YEARS,
THREE MONTHS.
WE JOINED THE UNION WHERE SOME
OF THE SCHOLARS TOLD US AS IF
YOU'RE ENTERING INTO PARTY VERY
LATE AT NIGHT WHEN PEOPLE ARE
ALREADY A LITTLE TIPSY AND
LEAVING HOME.
THIS WAS A COMMENT BY NIALL
FERGUSON I SPOKE TO HIM WHEN HE
WAS IN CROATIA A FEW YEARS AGO.
A FEW YEARS LATER, HIS OWN
COUNTRY IS ON THE WAY UP.
THIS IS A BIT OF A PARADOX AS
YOU CAN SEE.
A FEW MONTHS AGO, WE ALL
CELEBRATED THE 60th ANNIVERSARY
OF THE EU.
-- 16th ANNIVERSARY.
SHOULD BEEN A MOMENT OF NEW
ENTHUSIASM, NEW ENCOURAGEMENT
AND REINVIGORATING THE SPIRIT
OF THE FOUNDING FATHERS WHO
SIGNED THE TREATY IN 1957.
THIS WAS ALSO THE MOMENT TO TRY
AND EMBRACE THE ROME AGENDA
DECLARATION OR REMIND OURSELVES
OF THE VALUES THE UNION IS
BUILT ON.
THESE VALUES ARE INDEED PEACE,
DEMOCRACY, READ THEM, THE RULE
OF LAW, MARKET ECONOMY.
I WOULD SAY EVEN TODAY, WITH
ALL THE DIFFICULTIES WE OBSERVE
AROUND THE GLOBE, THEY ARE
SIMILAR TO THE EU TODAY AS THEY
ARE FOR THE REST OF THE WORLD.
THESE INTERNAL CHALLENGES AND
GLOBAL CHALLENGES IN THE
ALTERED WORLD OF COMEDIC ASIAN
WHERE EVERYBODY IS COMEDIC
KIDDING WITH EVERYONE
INSTANTLY, SOMETIMES WITH
ARGUMENTS, OFTEN WITHOUT
ARGUMENTS IS CREATING A JOB FOR
THOSE WHO RUN THE EU AND MORE
DEMANDING THAN EVER BEFORE.
>> THE COMMISSION WHO HAS THIS
ROLE OF BEING A GUARDIAN OF THE
TREATIES BUT THE INITIATOR OF
FURTHER INTEGRATION HAS COME UP
WITH SEVERAL SCENARIOS.
THIS PAPER IN ITS VALIDITY IS
STILL A TOPIC WIDELY DISCUSSED
IN THE NUMBER OF MEMBER STATES
AND THE VARIOUS FORMS OF OUR
TRADITIONS.
YOU KNOW THE SCENARIOS.
WHETHER THE EU SHOULD GO BACK
TO THE SINGLE MARKETS AND
NOTHING ELSE?
WHETHER WE SHOULD ADOPT A
SCENARIO FOR THOSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO DO MORE ACTUALLY DO
MORE OR SHOULD WE DO LESS IN A
MORE EFFICIENT MANNER OR SHOULD
WE DO MORE TOGETHER?
THESE FIVE SCENARIOS, NONE
EXCLUSIVE.
EVEN IN THE WORDS OF THE
COMMISSION PRESIDENT WHO HAD
THE STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS
LAST WEEK, HE PROPOSED A SIXTH
SCENARIO.
I'VE BEEN SAYING ALL ALONG THAT
WE NEED TO DO A MIXTURE BECAUSE
THE OPTICS OF MEMBER STATES IS
NOT THAT MUCH ALIGNED AS IT WAS
20 TO 25 YEARS AGO WHEN WE HAD
THE BIGGEST ENLARGEMENT.
>> WHAT WE NEED IS A SENSE OF
REALISM AND A DOSE OF OPTIMISM
FOR THE PROJECT TO SUCCEED AND
FOR THE PROJECT TO BE AS
ATTRACTIVE AS IT WAS BEFORE.
AND A MODEL FOR ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE GLOBE.
>> AT THIS POWER OF ATTRACTION
SERVES AS AN INSTRUMENT FOR
TRANSFORMATION OF THOSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE PART OF THE
CLUB.
FROM MY POINT OF VIEW AND MY
COUNTRY'S POINT OF VIEW,
CROATIA IS A CLEAR EXAMPLE OF
HOW IT TRIES TO BECOME EVER
CLOSER IN THE NARROW CIRCLE OF
THE EUROPEAN UNION INTEGRATION.
WE HAVE TWO STEPS WHICH ARE
AHEAD OF US.
TO OVERARCHING PROCESSES AND
REFORMS WHICH WILL STRENGTHEN
OUR BELONGING TO THE EUROPEAN
PROJECT.
ONE IS TO JOIN AREA OF FREE
MOVEMENT DO TO THE REFUGEE AND
MIGRATION CRISIS.
IT HAS BEEN AN UNPRECEDENTED
SITUATION DUE TO CHANGES IN
POVERTY AND CONFLICT IN MIDDLE
EAST AND AFRICA.
NOT ONLY BORDER CONTROLS HAVE
BEEN RAISED BUT PHYSICAL
BARRIERS AND WIRES HAVE BEEN
INSTATED IN SOME BORDERS.
VERY FEW PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
ANTICIPATED OR ENVISIONED SUCH
A SCENARIO WHERE THE FREEDOM OF
MOMENTS WAS ONE OF THE MAIN
LIBERTIES BUT ONE OF THE
GREATEST ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE
PROJECT.
>> FROM THAT POINT OF VIEW,
CROATIA HAS ANOTHER GOAL TO
OBTAIN THAT IS TO JOIN YOUR.
IT'S NOT AN ELKHART PROJECT.
WHEN WE WANTED TO JOIN THERE
WAS NOT AN OPTION.
WHEN WE SIGNED THE TREATY IN
2011, WE AGREED TO FILL --
FULFILL -- IN A FEW WEEKS FROM
TODAY, WE WILL BE LAUNCHING A
CAMPAIGN FOR THE EURO ZONE
EXPRESSION.
IT'S AN EXERCISER TO BETWEEN
THE GOVERNMENT AND CORPORATIONS
NATIONAL BANK.
THE GENERAL CALENDAR IN FRONT
OF US IS TO MANAGE TO BECOME A
PART OF THE EXCHANGE RATE
MECHANISM SOMETIME IN 2020 AND
THEN A FEW YEARS AFTER THAT TO
BECOME A FULLY FLEDGED MEMBER
OF THE EURO ZONE.>> WHERE MY
MAIN POINTS?
WHAT ARE THE THREE ELEMENTS
WHICH I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
STRENGTHENED OR IMPROVED?
FIRST, TO STRENGTHEN THE
DEMOCRATIC LEGITIMACY OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND THEIR
OFFICIALS.
THIS IS SOME PART OF THE
FAILURE I WILL REFER LATER ON
TO IN A SERIES OF UNSUCCESSFUL
VARIOUS KEY ISSUES IN MEMORY OF
THEM -- MANY OF THE MEMBER
STATES OF EU.
SECOND IS TO ENSURE BETTER
RESULTS OF THE REDISTRIBUTIVE
POWER OF THE EU BUDGETS AND THE
IMPACT OF OUR COMMON POLICIES
ON A CONCRETE DAILY LIFE.>> WE
NEED TO SOMEHOW TRANSFORM THE
ABSTRACT GOOD INTO CONCRETE
BENEFITS OF EACH AND EVERY
CITIZEN OF THE EU.
THE THIRD ELEMENT IS THE
INFLUENCE OF THE EU ON THE
GLOBAL SCENE AND GLOBAL
GOVERNANCE INCLUDING
ORGANIZATIONS.
>> FOR MANY REASONS, ONE IS THE
RISE OF POPULISM ACROSS THE
MEMBER STATES OF THE EU, WE
SOMEHOW FEEL THE INCREASING
LACK OF CONFIDENCE IN THE
PROJECT.
>> I BECAME FULLY AWARE OF THIS
PHENOMENA IN 2014.
DURING THE EUROPEAN PARLIAMENT
ELECTIONS.
WE HAD TWO FEATURES DESPITE THE
FACT MY OWN POLITICAL FAMILY
MANAGED TO WIN THOSE ELECTIONS,
TO HAVE OUR REPRESENTATIVE AS A
PRESIDENT OF THE COMMISSION AND
OF THE EUROPEAN COUNCIL WE HAD
ALL THREE MAJOR INSTITUTIONS.
NONETHELESS, THE 2014 ELECTIONS
WERE SIGNAL OF A NEW PHENOMENA.
ONE, IN SOME COUNTRIES
INCLUDING MINE, THE
PARTICIPATION WAS LOW.
BELOW EXPECTATIONS OF PEOPLE
STILL COULDN'T GRASP WHY WE
SHOULD HAVE THE ELECTED IN A
BODY OF 751.>> SECOND,
PHENOMENA WAS THE RELATIVE
WINNERS IN THE BIG COUNTRIES,
SOME THE FOUNDING MEMBERS WERE
THE PARTIES.
YOU SOUGHT IN THE UK.
YOU SOUGHT IN FRANCE AS THE
NATIONAL FRONT.
YOU SOUGHT IN SPAIN.
YOU SOUGHT IN ITALY.
YOU COULD SEE IT ALSO IN
GERMANY IN THE SENSE THERE BE A
RELATIVE WINTER BUT FOR THE
FIRST TIME EVER, THEY GOT SEVEN
SEATS.
>> NOT TO MENTION THE RESULTS
IN POLAND WHERE SOME OF THE
PARTIES PUT UP PURELY EUROPEAN
AGENDA.
IN A WAY, THE EUROPEAN
ELECTIONS NOT ONLY BECOME A
MOMENTS WHERE YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS AGAINST
NATIONAL GOVERNMENTS OR THE
MOMENTS OF NATIONAL POLITICS
BUT ALSO AS A PLATFORM WHERE
POPULIST PARTIES WITH ANTI-
EUROPEAN AGENDA GETS INTO THE
EU INSTITUTION AND USE THEM
AGAINST THE PROJECT
>> THIS WAS SO PLASTICKY
VISIBLE IN THE CASE OF A
SUBSEQUENT REFERENDUM IN THE
UK.
>> I ALWAYS SAID WHEN THE FIRST
TIME I READ THE SPEECH OF DAVID
CAMERON THAT WAS GOING TO CALL
THE END TO BRITISH DEBATES ON
THE MEMBERSHIP IN THE EEO -- EU
THAT WAS AN UNNECESSARY
EXERCISE IT WOULDN'T DO ANY
GOOD TO ANYONE.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A LOW
SITUATION FOR HIM AND FOR HIS
PARTY.
A LOSE SITUATION FOR THE UK,
LOSE SITUATION FOR EU AND LOSE
SITUATION WHEN WE PAUL THE LINE
-- DRAW THE LINE AND
EVERYTHING, LOW SITUATION
GLOBALLY.
WHEN A PERMANENT MEMBER OF THE
SECURITY COUNCIL LEAVES THE
CLUB IN THE COUNTRY WHO HAS ONE
OF THE MOST STRONGEST DEFENSE
FORCES IN THE CLUB WHO IS A
CHAMPION OF THE FREE TRADE
DECIDES TO LEAVE WHICH IS ONE
PREDOMINANTLY BY MANIPULATION
OF ANTI-EUROPEAN FORCES WHO USE
THEIR POSITION ON THE STAGE OF
THE EUROPEAN PARLIAMENT IN A
WAY THEY ACTUALLY SPOKE ABOUT
EVERY THING BUT VERY LITTLE
ABOUT THE TRUTH, THEN WE HAVE A
PROBLEM.
DEMOCRACY AS SUCH HAS A
IT IS A PARADOX THAT PEOPLE
HAVE TO LIVE WITH.
WE HAVE TO FIND A SOLUTION.
A SIMILAR EXAMPLE OF A NEGATIVE
REFERENDUM WAS ORGANIZED IN
2016 THE REFERENDUM WHICH
ORGANIZED BY GROUP OF CATERS --
PROBABLY CATERS TO DISTRACT THE
NATIONAL POLICY AND WHEN I
PICKED UP WAS INTERESTING ISSUE
AND USE THE CITIZEN INITIATIVE
TO ORGANIZE THE REFERENDUM BY
ELECTRONICALLY COLLECTING
400,000 SIGNATURES.
IMAGINE ON THE REFERENDUM ON
THE CONCLUSION OF THE
ASSOCIATION AGREEMENT BETWEEN
UK AND EU.>> YOU CAN IMAGINE
THE SPAN OF POSSIBILITIES FOR
THE INFLUENCE AND THE INTERNAL
POLITICAL DEBATE.>> POSSIBILITY
ZERO, RESULT JUST ENOUGH TO
MAKE THE REFERENDUM VALID.
32% WHICH REPRESENT 0.61% OF
THE TOTAL POPULATION OF THE EU.
THE REFERENDUM CLEARLY -- NO,
WE DON'T WANT TO CONCLUDE.
WITH -- WHAT WERE THE LESSONS
LEARNED?
VERY FEW POLITICAL ACTORS
ACTUALLY COMMITTED TO FIGHT FOR
THE IDEA.
THE MAINSTREAM PARTIES WERE
LUKEWARM BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL
FACING ELECTIONS A YEAR LATER.
NONE WAS PROPERLY INVOLVED.
WHAT WE HAD IS A SIGNAL TO A
COUNTRY WHO LOST 10,000 PEOPLE
IN THE LAST THREE YEARS AFTER
REVELS SUPPORTED BY RUSSIA
TRIED TO DESTABILIZE THE
EUROPEAN ORIENTATION AND
TEMPORARILY OCCUPY PART OF THE
TERRITORY OF THE COUNTRY.
SENT A MESSAGE TO A COUNTRY
WHERE 10,000 PEOPLE HAVE DIED,
THE EUROPEAN FLAGS WHICH ARE --
WE WANT TO JOIN THE EU AND A
FEW SAY NO, WE DON'T WANT YOU.
YOU DON'T EVEN QUALIFY FOR A
WAITING ROOM.
YOU SHOULD BE FURTHER AWAY.
MORLEY AND INEFFABLY -- MORALLY
AND ETHICALLY, EXTREMELY
NEGATIVE.
WE ARE DISCUSSING THE COUNCIL,
A SPECIAL DOCUMENT, I SAID TO
FELLOW LEADERS IN A VERY CLEAR
MANNER THAT THIS IS BE A
DOCUMENT THAT SHOULD NOT BE
PUBLICIZED BECAUSE A LOT OF
THINGS IT MAY HAVE PUT THEIR AS
AN ACCOMMODATION TO DUTCH
RESIDENT BE PROUD OF.
AND -- ARE NOT SOMETHING TO BE
PROUD OF.
WE NEED TO FIGHT THE RISE OF
POPULISM.
WE NEED TO DO BY BEING
CREDIBLE.
FROM THAT POINT OF VIEW, THE
NEXT ELECTIONS WILL BE A
SERIOUS TEST FOR THE MAINSTREAM
PARTIES AND THE DEBATE OF THOSE
OR ORGANS THE PROJECT WILL BE
SEEN MORE THAN EVER.
WE ALL HAVE A STRONG TASK TO
ENGAGE MORE FORCEFULLY IN THE
CAMPAIGN AND THE DEBATE.>> WHEN
IT COMES TO EUROPEAN POLICIES,
WE WILL BE EMBARKING ON A
DISCUSSION OF THE FINANCIAL
FRAMEWORK.
IT'S THE EU BUDGET THAT LAST
FOR SEVEN YEARS WHICH IS 1% OF
TOTAL GDP OF EU.
AND ENTAILS HUNDRED 50 BILLION
EUROS A YEAR WHERE THESE ARE
COMMITMENTS OR PAYMENTS.
THIS IS ONLY 1%.
THE WAY WE SPEND IT'S, THE WAY
WE INVEST IN OUR AGRICULTURE
AND OUR REGIONAL DEVELOPMENTS,
THE WAY WE SUPPORT THE
PREVENTION OF YOUTH
UNEMPLOYMENT.
THE WAY WE INVEST IN SCIENCE
AND THE DIGITAL AGENDA, IT WILL
BE A TEST WHETHER WE ARE
SUCCESSFUL OR NOT OVER THE
EUROPEAN BUDGET BECAUSE AS AN
ADDED VALUE TO THE MORE EQUAL
AND FASTER CATCHING UP OF THOSE
COUNTRIES WHO ARE NOT AS
DEVELOPED AS THOSE PRIVILEGED
ENOUGH TO BE ON THE RIGHT SIDE
OF THE IRON CURTAIN.
THAT'S WERE CONCRETE OF ACT OF
OUR BUDGET AND POLICIES,
ESPECIALLY FOR THE COUNTRIES OF
OUR SIZE ARE CRITICAL.
IN A SENSE THAT WE EXPLAIN THE
EFFECT TO THE LIVING STANDARD
OF OUR CITIZENS IS GOING UP
BECAUSE OF THE MEMBERSHIP
ANOTHER TO BECOME SOME ALLUSIVE
CATEGORY.>> AND OTHER ELEMENTS
CRUCIAL IS THE GLOBAL ROLE OF
THE EUROPEAN UNION.
THIS IS INDEED THE RIGHT MOMENT
TO SAY IT'S.
WHEN THE SECRETARY-GENERAL OF
THE UNITED NATIONS SPEAKS ABOUT
REFORM OF THE WORLD
ORGANIZATION WHETHER IT'S
DEVELOPMENTS WERE PEACEKEEPING
WERE TRYING TO ADDRESS THE
TRENDS IN OUR GLOBALIZED WORLD
IN A MORE EFFICIENT MANNER. THE
EU CAN DO QUITE A LOT.
IT'S BECOMING GRADUALLY
OCCLUDED DEFENSE ORGANIZATION.
THERE IS NO PROPER COPY PASTE
AUTOMATISM BUT IT'S A DIRECTION
WHERE THE PROJECT IS GOING.
FROM THAT POINT OF VIEW, THE
UNION WHICH HAS STRONG FOREIGN
POLICY OF MEMBER STATES SHOULD
BE MORE COHESIVE ALTOGETHER.
ESPECIALLY IN THE CRISIS
SITUATIONS.
WHERE WE ARE SPENDING UP TO 2%
IS NOT SPENT IN A WAY WE ARE
ONLY FULFILLING OBLIGATIONS TO
HAVE FORCES WHICH ARE
INTEROPERABLE, QUICK TO REACT
AND COMPLEMENT TRADE WITH OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS.
A FOREIGN POLICY WHICH WOULD
CERTAINLY DRAW ON THE LARGE
POOL OF THE BILL -- OF THE
DEVELOPMENTS THAT THE UNION IS
DOING.
THAT'S HOW THE PROJECT STARTED
SIX YEARS AGO.
ALL ELEMENTS HAVE A FOREIGN
ELEMENT IN THE CONFERENCE OF
MANOR BE A PARTNER WHICH IS
RECOGNIZED BY ALL COLLECTORS
GLOBALLY AND A PARTNER THAT
REALLY MAKES A DIFFERENCE.
I FEEL WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY
COMPARED TO WHERE WE WERE 20-25
YEARS AGO.
EXPECTED A LOT. THE TOOLS
WEREN'T THERE.
A DIFFERENT ISSUE WHETHER THERE
WAS SUFFICIENT POLITICAL WILL,
THE TOOLS NOT PLACE.
THE TOOLS, LESSONS LEARNED, WE
HAVE MORE SPACE TO BE A
CREDIBLE INTERNATIONAL ACTOR.
THEY CAN BE COMBINED TO AN
EXTENT THAT OUR FOREIGN
ACTIVITIES ARE SEEN AS A POLICY
OF A EUROPEAN UNION THAT
PRIMARILY STANDS FIRMLY BEHIND
THE VALUES THAT IT HAS
INSTRUMENTS AND THE BUDGET TO
WAKE UP THESE VALUES AND
POLICIES.
THIS IS HOW WE BECOME A
RELEVANT PARTNER ON THE GLOBAL
SCENE.
THIS IS THE LINE MY GOVERNMENT
IS TAKING WITHIN THE INTERNAL
DEBATES.
THIS IS WHAT WE SHOULD ALSO
ADVOCATE WHEN WE REPRESENT OUR
COUNTRY SUCH AS THE UN GENERAL
ASSEMBLY.
I VERY MUCH AGREE WITH THE
PRESIDENT WHO SAYS EUROPE WAS
NOT AT A STANDSTILL.
ONE OF HIS FAMOUS PREDECESSOR
SAYS WE ARE LIKE A BICYCLE, AND
WE STOP RUNNING THE BICYCLE, WE
MIGHT FALL.
WE STILL WILL FIND ENOUGH FORCE
TO HAVE THIS PROJECT WHICH WAS
A PEACEFUL CONTINENTAL PROJECT
THE LAST 70 YEARS AS STRONG,
ATTRACTIVE OR EVEN CROATIAN
NEIGHBORS IN THE YEARS TO COME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SPIKE AT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
THOUGHT-PROVOKING COMMENTS MR.
PRIME MINISTER.
NOW I OPEN THE FLOOR FOR
DISCUSSION.
WE HAVE A MICROPHONE IN THE
MIDDLE.
PLEASE FORM A LINE BEHIND IT.
WHILE THE LINE IS BEING FORMED,
LET ME BREAK THE ICE WITH THE
FIRST QUESTION.
YOU ENDED YOUR PRESENTATION BY
SAYING YOUR WAS NOT MADE TO
STANSELL.
BUT IT WAS ALSO NOT MADE TO
SHRINK BUT TO ENLARGE.
THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY, WE
HAVE A SHRINKING YOU.
WHAT'S ARE THE CHANCES FOR EU
ENLARGEMENT AFTER BREXIT?
CROATIA WAS PUSHING FOR FURTHER
ENLARGEMENT OF THE EU TO COVER
COUNTRIES OF THE SOUTHEAST
EUROPE.
CAN YOU TELL US SOMETHING MORE
ABOUT IT?>> THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A LONG HISTORY TOGETHER
AND I'M HAPPY HE HAS BEEN ONE
OF OUR HIGHEST POSITIONED
DIPLOMATS IN THE SYSTEM OF THE
UNITED NATIONS.
ANDREW DUFF WHO IS A BRITISH
LIBERAL.
BARRY IS VERY EXPERIENCED AND
PROLIFIC WRITER.
HE SAID FOR MANY YEARS, THE EU
WAS DEVISING A PARKING POSITION
WHICH WOULD BE SOMETHING CLOSE
TO MEMBERSHIP.
HE TOLD ME PRIVATELY, SOMEHOW I
FEAR IF THE REFERENDUM IS
ORGANIZED, THIS PARKING LOT MAY
END UP BEING A LOT OF MY OWN
COUNTRY.
HE ANTICIPATED THE SHRINKING
SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
TO BE VERY OPEN, THERE ARE VERY
FEW COUNTRIES NOW OR STRONGLY
AND OPENLY ADVOCATING SWIFT
ENLARGEMENTS.
THE MOOD IS SIMPLY NOT THERE.
SOMEHOW THE DIGESTION OF THE
ENLARGEMENTS OF 2004 AND THEN
2007 AND IN 2013 IS STILL A
PROCESS.
THE ECONOMIC CRISIS, THE
PERENNIAL INSTITUTIONAL THE
BLADE -- DEBATE DEEPENING AND
WIDENING, RISE OF EXTREME
PARTIES HAS SHED A BIT OF A
FEAR IN THE MAINSTREAM OF THE
PARTIES WHO ALWAYS DRIVE THE
PROCESSES WHETHER WE WANT
MEDIUM OR SMALLER SIZE.
TO BE THE STRONG ADVOCATES OF
THE ELECTION.
WE, ON THE OTHER HAND SINCE WE
ARE THE LATECOMER TO THE CLUB
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE PROCESS.
SAYING OPENLY TO COUNTRIES WHO
WISH TO JOIN, NO WAY YOU ENTER
DURING MY WATCH IS IN MY VIEW
MORE DISSUASIVE THAN
ENCOURAGING.
I THINK WE SHOULD BE MORE
CAREFUL IN CALIBRATING THE
LANGUAGE.
THERE ARE SOME COUNTRIES AND
THE CLOSEST IS MONTENEGRO.
THEY ARE DOING FINE.
SERBIA IS MAKING A LOT OF
EFFORTS.
I STILL BELIEVE ANY SWIFT
ENLARGEMENT IS SIMPLY NOT
INSIDE.
IT WILL BE A CAREFULLY GUIDED
PROCESS.
PREDOMINANTLY THE CURRENT MOOD
AND THE PUBLIC'S AND THE KEY
POLITICAL PARTY.
>> I WOULD BE TEMPTED TO ASK
YOU MORE QUESTIONS INCLUDING
ABOUT UKRAINE ON WHICH YOU KNOW
A LOT.
BUT WE HAVE A LINE FORMED.
>> THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
I AM AN UNDERGRADUATE AT THE
SCHOOL OF GENERAL STUDIES.
I WANT TO ASK YOU, I HAVE HEARD
FROM SOME EUROPEANS WHO BELIEVE
EUROPEAN UNION POLICY IS
PRIMARILY DRIVEN BY FEW
COUNTRIES FOR THEIR BENEFITS
AND THESE COUNTRIES HAVE
SPECIAL PRIVILEGES WITHIN THE
EU THAT DON'T EXTEND TO ALL THE
COUNTRIES.
I WAS WONDERING IF THIS IS
TRUE, WHAT CAN BE DONE TO
CHANGE THIS AND IF THIS IS NOT
COMBAT THIS FALSE PERSPECTIVE?
>> LET'S TAKE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS AND THEN GIVE A
CHANCE TO THE PRIME MINISTER.
KNOWING THAT UNFORTUNATELY WE
DO NOT HAVE MUCH TIME.
JUST ASK ONE QUESTION AND
FOCUSED AND TO THE POINT.>>
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I AM FROM CHINA AND I AM IN THE
SCHOOL OF INTERNATIONAL AND
PUBLIC AFFAIRS FIRST-YEAR
STUDENT.
CEASED TO BE A HUGE ADVOCATE OF
THE INTEGRATIVE POLICY OF EU.
DO YOU BELIEVE A STANDARD
POLICY WILL HELP YOUR COUNTRY?
YOUR COUNTRY SITUATION IS
DIFFERENT FROM MANY OTHERS LIKE
GERMANY AND FRANCE WHICH ARE
HIGHLY DEVELOPED.
>> THANK YOU FOR YOUR ELEGANT
SPEECH.
I AM A SOPHOMORE.
CONSIDERING THE EU USUALLY
DEMANDS A NATION SELL SOLVES
ANY TERRITORY DISPUTES IT MAY
BE INVOLVED IN BEFORE BEING
ADMITTED TO THE BODY, THERE'S
AN ONGOING TERRITORY DISPUTE,
DOES THIS NECESSARILY PREVENT
CROATIAN ENTRY AND IF NOT,
WHAT'S THE MESSAGE DOES THIS
SEND TO OTHER COUNTRIES
ATTEMPTING TO JOIN WITH RESPECT
TO THE CREDIBILITY OF THE BODY
ITSELF AND THE PRACTICAL
QUESTION OF THE BORDER.
>> LET'S TAKE ONE LAST QUESTION
AND THEN GIVE THE FLOOR TO THE
PRIME MINISTER.
>> I AM A SOPHOMORE AT COLUMBIA
COLLEGE.
I HAD THE CHANCE TO PASS IN
TIME IN THE BALKANS.
UNFORTUNATELY IT WASN'T CROATIA
THAT I WAS STUDYING MIGRATION
AND REFUGEE CRISIS.
I'M INTERESTED, CROATIA IS ON
THE WAY THROUGH SOUTHEAST
EUROPE TO COUNTRIES LIKE
GERMANY.
THERE WERE CONCERNS OVER
BORDERS.
AND WHAT MISSION IS --
INITIATIVES CROATIA SHOULD TAKE
IN REGARDS TO TAKING REFUGEES.
>> THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
QUESTIONS.
WE SHOULD HAVE BUT THE FIRST
WHETHER THE EU SERVES ONLY A
FEW COUNTRIES OR THE WHOLE CLUB?
WHEN I CAME TO THE EUROPEAN
PARLIAMENT, I DELIBERATELY
WANTED TO JOIN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
WHEN YOU JOIN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE, YOU GET A LOOK AT
THE NUMBERS.
THEN YOU CAN ONLY PROPERLY SEE
WHAT ARE THE REAL PRIORITIES OF
THE ORGANIZATION.
THESE NUMBERS ARE REVEALING.
OUT OF 28 COUNTRIES, 10
COUNTRIES CONTRIBUTE TO THE 80%
OF THE BUDGET.
THOSE WHO CONTRIBUTE ARE THOSE
WHO ARE ECONOMICALLY MOST
DEVELOPED OR BIGGEST BY SIZE
AND THROUGH A VERY DEVELOPED
SYSTEM.
NEVERTHELESS, THE SMALLER
COUNTRIES GET THEIR PORTION OF
THE BUDGET.
WHAT WE ALL SHARE ARE THE SAME
POLICIES.
THESE ARE KEY.
EUROPE IS A PROJECT MADE BY
LAW.
IT CREATES CERTAINTY, PREDICT
ABILITY, RELIABILITY, AND IT
GIVES YOU AN INTERNATIONAL
LEGITIMACY.
THAT'S WHY EVEN IF YOU ARE
BIGGER, MEDIUM-SIZE OR SMALL
YOU CAN PROFIT FROM THE
PROJECT.
THE IDEA IS YOUR INSTITUTIONS,
THE PEOPLE WHO WORK ON THE EU
WHETHER IT'S THE FUNDING, THE
IMITATION, SIBLEY DO IN THE
MOST EFFICIENT MANNER.
THOSE WHO ARE EFFICIENT GET
MORE PROFIT.
I WOULDN'T SAY THEIR THOSE ARE
PRIVILEGED AND THE PROJECT WAS
ONLY INTENDED FOR THE FEW OF
THE 28.
THE OTHER QUESTION IS ABOUT THE
FLEXIBILITY.
CROATIA IS DOING WELL.
IN TERMS OF ECONOMIC GROWTH.
IN TERMS OF ECONOMIC STRENGTH,
EXPORTS, INDUSTRY AND MANY
OTHER INDICATORS THERE ARE
OTHER COUNTRIES ARE FAR MORE
DEVELOPED.
THIS IS A DIFFERENCE.
THE IDEA IS THE EU POLICIES
HELP US TO SHORTEN THE TIME
FRAME SO AS TO CATCH UP WITH
THOSE ARE BETTER DEVELOPED.
THAT'S HOW MY COUNTRY SEES THE
EU POLICIES AND BUDGET.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR YOU
TO UNDERSTAND THERE'S NO LEGAL
PRECONDITIONS.
I ALWAYS SAY THE EU IS NOT A
SUBSTITUTE TO INTERNATIONAL
LAW.
BORDERS ARE VERY MUCH
COMPETENCE OF MEMBER STATES.
IT WILL BE EXCELLENT IF ALL
BORDERS WOULD BE SOLVED BUT I
HAVE NEVER WITNESSED THE WORK
OF A BELGIAN DUTCH COMMISSION
ON THE DEMARCATION OF THEIR
BORDER WHICH IS NOW BEING
ACTIVE 400 YEARS HAS REACHED
THE TABLE OF THE COLLEGE OF THE
COMMISSIONERS OR EVEN ANY
COMMITTEE OF EUROPEAN
PARLIAMENT.
THE POINT IS, WE SHOULD
DISTINGUISH WHICH ARE THE
DOSSIERS THAT YOU HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL CONNECTION AND
WHICH OF THOSE THAT ARE
NONETHELESS LEFT THE MEMBER
STATES TO SOLVE.
CROATIA, SLOVENIA BORDER ISSUE
IS ONE OF THOSE RESIDUAL
ELEMENTS OF THE DISSOLUTION.
THE WATER SHOULD BE ESTABLISHED
AS IT WAS ON THE 25th OF JUNE
1991.
ON THE DAY GRACIOUS PARLIAMENT
DECLARED OUR INDEPENDENCE.
THE WORK OF THE TWO COUNTRIES
IS THE WORK ON DETAILS.
IN 2009, AFTER SLOVENIA BLOCKED
THE NEGOTIATIONS WHICH IN MY
VIEW WERE UNRELATED BECAUSE OF
THE OPEN BORDER ISSUES IN GOOD
FAITH INTO SOMETHING WHICH IS
BASICALLY AN AD HOC ARBITRATION
WHERE SLOVENIA AND CROATIA
ALLOCATED ONE JUDGE EACH AND
THE THREE OTHER JUDGES WITH THE
HELP OF THE EUROPEAN COMMISSION
WERE FROM FRANCE, FROM THE UK
AND GERMANY.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT WE WENT
INTO THIS PROCESS IN GOOD
FAITH, THE PROCESS WAS
COMPROMISED DUE TO THE CORRECT
BEHAVIOR BETWEEN THE SLOVENIAN
AGENT AND THE SLOVENIAN JUDGE
THUS REVEALING THE DATA THAT
SHOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN MADE
KNOWN TO ONE OF THE PARTIES.
IN OUR PARLIAMENT, WE
UNANIMOUSLY DECIDED TO WITHDRAW
FROM THE ARBITRATION AND WE
DULY NOTIFIED EVERYONE.>> AS A
LAWYER, I WOULD'VE THOUGHT THE
ARBITERS IF THEY ARE DECIDING
ON THE CASE WHERE ONE PARTY
DECIDES TO LEAVE SHOULD HAVE
SAID IMMEDIATELY, WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO DO?
HOW CAN WE CONTINUE THE PROCESS
OR ONE OF THE PARTIES IS NOT
PARTICIPATING?
THEY ACTUALLY DID CONTINUE.
THIS IS SOMETHING I WOULD CALL
EXTREMELY UNUSUAL PROGRESSIVE
POLITICIAN, I WOULD CALL IT
UNACCEPTABLE.
THEY DELIVERED AN ARBITRATION
AWARD LATE JUNE THIS YEAR.
THAT ESTABLISHED BY A LARGE THE
LINE THAT CROATIA WAS
ADVOCATING ALL ALONG IN TERMS
OF THE LAND BORDERS SHOULD BE
ACCEPTED.
WITH SOME SMALLER ACCEPTION.
ON THE LIMITATION THEY FOLLOWED
ANOTHER LATERAL ATTEMPT 2011
WHEN IT COMES TO ONE AREA OF
CREATION AND SLOVENIAN CLOSE
CALL.
COURSE, THE LINE WHICH GOES OUT
TO TOUCH THE TERRITORIAL SEA.
NOW THE POSITION OF MY
GOVERNMENT IS TO EMBARK ON
BILATERAL NEGOTIATIONS WAS
LAVINIA TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE AND SAW THAT.
SLOVENIA WOULD LIKE TO
IMPLEMENT THE WORD.
IT WILL REQUIRE A LOT OF
MATURITY AND SKILL.
POLITICAL COURAGE AND MEDICS
SKILL TO THE SOLUTION THERE
PROVIDE IS AN ISSUE THAT HAS BY
AND LARGE UNDULY BURDENED
OTHERWISE VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIPS WE HAVE BETWEEN
CROATIA AND SLOVENIA.
WE WILL CONTINUE PREPARING
POLITICALLY, WE WILL JOIN AND
WE WILL NOT ACCEPT ANY
SITUATIONS WHERE OUR MEMBERSHIP
WOULD BE PENDING ON SOLVING
PROBLEMS WHICH ARE UNRELATED.
>> ON MIGRATION, CROATIA WAS ON
THE EASTERN BUT ATTORNEY AND
ROOTS ESPECIALLY IN 2015, 2016.
THE ESTIMATE SAYS AROUND
700,000 PEOPLE PASSED THROUGH
CROATIA BECAUSE PREDOMINANTLY
THE DESTINATION WAS GERMANY OR
SOME OF THE COUNTRIES OF
WESTERN EUROPE WHERE THE RIGHTS
GIVEN TO ASYLUM-SEEKERS WERE
FAR MORE COMFORTING THAN THE
ONES IN OUR COUNTRY.
YOU MENTIONED YOU SHOW
SOLIDARITY AND WE AS A MEMBER
STATES WHO UNDERSTANDS THERE
SHOULD BE BURDEN SHARING AMONG
THE EU MEMBER STATES WILLING TO
ACCEPT AND BASICALLY HAVE AS A
HOST, THOSE MIGRANTS ARE
REFUGEES WHICH WOULD BE WITHIN
THE QUOTA IS SUPPOSED TO
RECEIVE.
AN ISSUE OF SOLIDARITY WAS
NEVER QUESTIONED AND CROATIA,
ESPECIALLY NOT TO GOVERNMENTS
AND UNLIKE SOME OTHER STATES WE
NEVER OPTED FOR A BARBED WIRE
ON OUR BORDERS.>>> THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
WE DO NOT HAVE TIME FOR ANOTHER
FULL ROUND OF QUESTIONS.
ONLY OF QUESTIONS CAN BE
TELEGRAPHIC IF YOU WANT TO
EXPOSE YOURSELF TO SUCH A
CHALLENGE THAT ANSWERS ARE VERY
SHORT.
PLEASE BE QUICK.
WE NEED TO DEPART IN 10 MINUTES.
>> I AM IN COLUMBIA COLLEGE,
I'M A FRESHMAN.
YOU TALKED EXTENSIVELY ABOUT
EUROPEAN INTEGRATION AND
NOTABLY THE BENEFITS OF THAT
INTEGRATION EXPENSED BY
ORDINARY CITIZENS.
TO THAT END, WHAT CHALLENGES OR
FORMS DOMESTICALLY DC AS MOST
PRESSING AND HOW DOES YOUR
GOVERNMENT INTEND TO PROCEED?>>
THANK YOU, YOU'RE REALLY
QUICK.>> THANK YOU COME TO OUR
CAMPUS.
I'M AN UNDERGRADUATE STUDYING
MATHEMATICS.
MY QUESTION IS REGARDING THE
LARGE NUMBER OF EDUCATED AND
SKILLED CROATIANS LEAVING THE
HOMELAND AND WHAT IS YOUR
GOVERNMENT AIMING TO DO FOR THE
SHORT-TERM AND LONG-TERM TO
ADDRESS THIS?
DO YOU THINK THIS IS
UNAVOIDABLE?>>
>> I WAS HOPING TO HEAR YOUR
THOUGHTS AND THE FUTURE OF THE
EU ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
EVER CLOSER UNION WHICH YOU ARE
DISCUSSING.
IN LIGHT OF THE SKEPTICISM THAT
HAS SURFACED WITH THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION AND THE U.S.>>
I'M A VISITING UNDERGRADUATE
FROM GERMANY.
I HAVE A QUESTION REGARDING
INTRODUCTION OF THE EURO
CURRENCY.
IT'S REQUIRED LOWER YOUR
NATIONAL DEBT TO 60%. I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK HOW YOU TRIED TO
CONVINCE THE CROATIAN CITIZENS
TO ACCEPT THAT INTRODUCTION
CONSIDERING THE MEASURES
NECESSARY TO LOWER NATIONAL
DEBT.>> I'M A STUDENT AT THE
SCHOOL OF PROFESSIONAL STUDIES.
I'VE HEARD FROM SOME CROATIANS
THERE HAS BEEN EFFORTS OF
BLACKMAILING FROM SLOVENIA AND
HUNGARY.
I WAS IN A, WAS YOUR OPINION ON
THAT?
IS IT TRUE AND IF IT IS, WHAT
HAS BEEN YOUR GOVERNMENT'S
RESPONSE TO IT?>> THERE WAS A
QUESTION ON THE DOMESTIC
REFORMS.
THAT WOULD REQUIRE ANOTHER
OCCASION WITH ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT SUBJECT AS
INTRODUCTION.
IF I MAY SAY, THE AMBITION OF
MY GOVERNMENT IS TO EMBARK ON
SERIOUS STRUCTURAL REFORMS THAT
CROATIAN SOCIETY AND
INSTITUTIONS REQUIRE.
THAT WOULD NOT ONLY TOUCH THE
REFORM OF THE STATE
ADMINISTRATION, THE REFORM OF
JUDICIARY, THE REFORM OF OUR
HEALTH SYSTEM, PENSION SYSTEM,
THE REFORM OF OUR EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM.
IT WOULD REQUIRE THE FULL
IMITATION OF THE DOCUMENT WHICH
WE CALL THE NATIONAL PROGRAM OF
REFORMS WHICH IS AN ANNUAL
DOCUMENT WE ADOPT IN SPRING.
BEEN THROUGH A CONCEPT CALLED
-- WE ARE CAREFULLY MONITORING
AND WATCHED BY THE COMMISSION
WHETHER WE OBTAIN THESE
OBJECTIVES.
THIS IS A TASK OF EACH AND
EVERY MINISTER.
THIS IS AN AMBITION WE ALL
SHARE.
THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
ELECTED FOR.
TO UNDERTAKE THOSE REFORMS FROM
THE PERIOD OF 2016 UNTIL 2020
WHEN CROATIA WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHAIR AND BE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE COUNCIL.>>
WHEN IT CAME TO THE QUESTION OF
THE UNITED STATES ROLE IN THE
EU POLICIES, WE HAVE SEEN EVERY
MONTH AN EVOLUTIONARY PROCESS
IN TERMS OF GENERAL APPROACH TO
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS AND
POLICY AND MULTILATERALISM BY
THE DEMONSTRATION AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
I SAID YESTERDAY BEFORE THE
CROATIAN MEDIA THAT FOR ME HIS
SPEECH WAS SOMETHING THAT I WAS
NOT EXPECTING.
HE STILL MAINTAINED AMERICA
FIRST AND ENCOURAGED ALL OF US
TO SAY CROATIA FIRST OR
SLOVENIA OR WHATEVER.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
MESSAGE YESTERDAY.
WE WILL CONTINUE DIALOGUE.
A TREATY THAT WOULD HAVE
CREATED FAR MORE JOBS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE ATLANTIC AND
ENABLED US TO TRADE MUCH MORE
THAN IT WAS BEFORE.
THIS IS SOMETHING A TASK FOR
MANY OF THE EUROPEAN LEADERS
WHERE THEY SPEAK AS ONE.
ON THE EURO CURRENCY, I'M HAPPY
YOU ARE CAREFULLY OBSERVING THE
CRITERIA.
WE ARE LOWING THE PUBLIC DEBT
STEADILY.
IS A CLEAR TIMEFRAME HOW WE
INTEND TO GO DOWN TO 60.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW THE CRITERIA
ARE LITTLE BIT MORE
SOPHISTICATED THAN JUST
REACHING THE 60.
THE IDEA IS THE TREND.
THE CROATIAN PUBLIC KNOWS WHEN
WE SIGNED THE TREATY IN 2011 WE
WILL ALREADY COMMITTED TO
BECOME PART OF THE ZONE.
WE COULD REQUIRE ANOTHER
REFERENDUM CONSULTATION WITH
THE POPULATION BECAUSE WHEN
THEY VOTED ON 22 JANUARY 2012,
BY CLEAR VOTE, 66-33.
THEY VOTED THAT CROATIA JOINS
THE EURO ZONE.>> THE LAST
QUESTION WAS MORE OF A QUESTION
LINKING WHAT THE CURRENT
STUDENTS ARE SAVED OTHER
STUDENTS ABOUT THE MEMBERSHIP
BY TWO NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES.
IS THE ONLY ORGANIZATION WHERE
THEY COULD TECHNICALLY BECOME A
MEMBER.
IT'S AN ORGANIZATION WHICH
WOULD GIVE US A FINAL STAMP
THAT WE HAVE DONE EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE IN TERMS OF
TRANSITION, TRANSFORMATION,
FUNCTIONING INSTITUTION
CREDIBILITY OF OUR LEGAL SYSTEM
AND THE LEVERAGE WE ARE PART OF
A GROUP OF STATES ACROSS THE
GLOBE WHO HAVE ATTAINED
STANDARDS FOR THOSE NOT IN THE
CLUB HABITS.
THOSE MEMBER STATES WERE PART
OF THE CLUB SHOULD SUPPORT
THOSE WHO ARE MEMBERS BUT NOT
YET MEMBERS OF THE ICD.
INSTEAD OF BLACKMAIL I WOULD
SAY WE WITNESS IS A VIOLATION
OF THE COMMON POSITION OF 2007.
EACH COUNTRY FROM ITS OWN
PERSPECTIVE.
ONE TRYING TO LINK THE
LIMITATION THAT CROATIA DOES
NOT EXIST BUT WE ARE SAYING WE
WILL DISCUSS THE OPEN BILATERAL
ISSUE ON BORDERS AND AN ISSUE
THAT HAS A D FROM THEIR OPTICS
PROTECTION OF THEIR INVESTMENTS
IN THE COMPANY WHICH IS
PRIVATIZING BOUGHT BY HUNGARIAN
OIL COMPANY ON TWO OCCASIONS
BUT THERE'S A DISPUTE,
ARBITRATION AND THE OTHER ONE
IS STILL ACTIVE.
OTHER ISSUES OF CORRUPTION AND
EXTREMELY COMPLEX ISSUE WHERE
OUR POSITION IS THAT THOSE
LEGAL ELEMENTS SHOULD NOT BE
MIXED WITH POLITICAL AMBITION
OF CROATIA TO BECOME A MEMBER
OF THE OICD.
WE HAVE CONVEYED THIS MESSAGE
TO SLOVENIAN AND HUNGARIAN
SIDES.
WE LEARNED OUR LESSON THAT THE
BLACKMAILING IS SIMPLY A NO GO.
IT WILL NOT PASS, IT WILL NOT
FLY.
AS MEMBER OF THE EU, I CAN PLAY
THE SAME GAME WHENEVER I WOULD
LIKE TO DO THAT BUT THOSE ARE
THE MOVES WHICH YOU DON'T DO.
NOT TO COUNTRIES THAT HAVE BEEN
STANDING BY YOU FOR CENTURIES
AND WOULD REMAIN THERE.
>> IN CONCLUDING, LET ME THANK
PRIME MINISTER FOR BEING A
GUEST OF COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY
AND GLOBAL POLICY INITIATIVE.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SAY THAT
YOU HAVE CLEARLY REFLECTED THAT
EUROPEAN DREAM IS NOT ONLY GOOD
FOR EUROPE BUT IT'S GOOD FOR
THE WORLD AS WELL.
GOOD LUCK TO THE EU, GOOD LUCK
TO CROATIA, GOOD LUCK TO YOU
PERSONALLY IN PURSUING THIS
DREAM.
YOU WERE LATE BUT YOU STAYED
LONGER AND ANSWERED ALL
QUESTIONS.>> I REALIZE I FORGOT
ONE.[ APPLAUSE ]
>>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THERE WAS ONE OF THE MANY
ISSUES OF CROATIANS LEAVING.
THIS IS A TREND WHICH THAT IS
CHARACTERISTIC FOR MANY OF THE
COUNTRIES OF CENTRAL AND
EASTERN EUROPE.
I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS WORKING
IN PARIS IN 2005.
THERE WAS A REFERENDUM AT THE
TIME AND THAT'S WHAT STARTED TO
GO WRONG.
ALL THE PLUMBERS IN FRANCE
WOULD LOSE THEIR JOBS BECAUSE
THERE BE -- FLYING IN LARGE
NUMBERS.
QUITE A FEW CROATIANS OF THE
LAST FEW YEARS NOT ONLY THIS
YEAR HAVE TRIED TO SEE IF THEY
COULD FIND A BETTER JOB, BETTER
LEAVING IN THE COUNTRIES OF
WESTERN EUROPE.
IT'S NOT A TREND WE ARE HAPPY
ABOUT.
IT IS A TASK, AND A TASK -- AN
EXTRA TASK FAMILIES COULD FIND
THEIR JOB IN CROATIA, HAVE A
SUSTAINABLE INCOME SO AS TO
RENT OR BUILD OR BUY HOUSE HAVE
A PROPER JOB THIS IS ALSO
LINKED TO A NEGATIVE
DEMOGRAPHIC TREND WE ARE
OFFICIALLY ONE OF THOSE NATIONS
WHO ARE LOSING PEOPLE EVERY
DAY.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST SERIOUS
TASKS MY GOVERNMENT HAS.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO BE A PROPHET
WHETHER WE CAN STOP THIS BY
SOME MIRACULOUS POLICIES.
WITH ALL THE POLICIES I
MENTIONED IN TERMS OF
STRUCTURAL FORMS, IF WE CREATE
ENOUGH CONDITIONS TO REMAIN IN
THE NUMBER OF THOSE WERE OPTED
TO GO ABROAD WOULD DIMINISH.
AT THE SAME TIME, YOU'RE
SELLING REFERENDUM OF
MEMBERSHIP TO THE PUBLIC WE
SAID THIS IS GOOD.
YOU HAVE A CHANCE AT MOBILITY.
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO SPEND A
PART OF YOUR WORKING LIFE OR
STUDY PERIOD STUDYING SOMEWHERE
ELSE, REQUIRING EXTRA KNOWLEDGE
COMING BACK IN BRINGING THIS
INTO CROATIAN SOCIETY.
IT'S A TWO-WAY PROCESS.
IS AN AREA VERY MUCH AFFECTED
BY WAR.
STILL THE POLICIES ARE ORIENTED
TO INVEST IN THAT PART SO AS TO
PREVENT GREATER FLOW OF
MIGRATION OF OUR YOUNG.
SECRETARY I SEE YOU'RE HAVING
I SEE HER ENTOURAGE WAS A SPARE
YOU A DIFF MEDIC INCIDENTS IF
YOU'RE LATE FOR ANOTHER EVENTS.
THANK YOU.